Hey, David.
Trump is talking about not knowing the results
of this election four days, weeks or months.
When do you think we will know who won the
2020 election?
So about three weeks ago, I would have said
to you it could be seven days after November
3rd.
So, like by November 10th, we will know the
results.
With every passing day, I actually think we
will probably know the results not much later
than November 4th.
I think the day after the election, I don't
believe this is going to be close enough that
we will need a full week to know the results.
Now, if and whether Donald Trump concedes
if he loses.
That's a very different question.
But I am increasingly blue when you look at
there are basically the issue is absentee
ballots in a normal election, according to
the Brookings Institute.
About 30 percent of the ballots that are cast
would be expected to be mailed in.
It is now expected to be more than half.
And there are basically three scenarios for
when states can count absentee ballots.
States can just start counting as they come
in before Election Day, meaning they're already
counting mail in ballots in some states.
There are states where the absentee ballots
can start to be counted at the in the morning
before the polls close, even if they have.
Been mailed in, so November 3rd in the morning,
people start voting in person and they start
opening and counting absentee ballots.
And then the third scenario is only when the
polls close can you start counting absentee
ballots.
The vast majority of states that matter are
not in that last category.
And it escapes me now.
But there are two states I, I want to say
Pennsylvania and one other of the states that
are in the last category where the results
may take a while to have from the absentee
ballots.
There are very few that have a shot at making
a difference in the results.
Now, Pennsylvania certainly is one of them.
And the reason why I am increasingly thinking
it's not going to take a week to know the
results is that Pennsylvania is going more
and more in the direction of Joe Biden this
week.
In fact, we had polls saying Joe Biden is
up eight in Pennsylvania or even more.
And that is the one.
There may be one other.
That is one of the few states that could be
a deciding state that has this.
We don't start counting until the polls close.
Sort of scenario.
And I may even be misremembering that.
Bottom line, the gist is I think the election
results being delayed will have more to do
with whether Donald Trump successfully uses
lawyers and courts to slow down or stop the
counting of absentee ballots and or to get
ballots dismissed, which he successfully did
in Iowa this week or last week.
I think it will have more to do with that
than the actual time it will take to count
the ballots.
I think that if the ballots are allowed to
be counted normally without interference,
that this is going to be an election where
we know the results on November 4th.
Now, that could be like midnight as November
5th is starting.
I think the real chance for a delay would
be Donald Trump creating one through using
lawyers, courts, lawsuits and the like.
Let's hope it doesn't happen.
Let's hope it is.
So a blow out for Joe Biden, which depends
on us that it doesn't even matter that even
on election night, it becomes clear that Joe
Biden won.
It could happen.
The next few weeks will determine ultimately
what does happen.